[Musique]
quand la cinquième bague de kobe de 19 à
déferler au pays les centres de
dépistage se sont vite retrouvés
débordés
si bien que plusieurs gouvernements dont
celui du québec en ont restreint l'accès
mais comment suivre d'épidémies sans
indication claire du nombre de cas dans
la population ma collègue lucie à
berdoues nous l'expliquent
[Musique]
6800 cas c'est ce qu'on anticipe
aujourd'hui la
mi-décembre au québec
devant les centres de dépistage les
files d'attentes s'allongent aussi vite
que grimpe la courbe des infections dans
la population le variant au micron du
virus de la copie de 19 serait pas à
vitesse grand v et le dépistage demeure
un problème quand est ce qu'on va se
faire tester au tournant de l'année le
bilan officiel dépasse les 18 mille cas
quotidiens près d'un test sur trois est
positif
le réseau sature
jamais vu le talent qu'on ne lui en veux
tu fasses
désormais la plupart des gens n'auront
plus accès aux tests diagnostiques par
pcr à partir de ce moment là le nombre
d'infections rapporté va chuter bien sûr
mais comment savoir ce que ça signifie
depuis le début de la pandémie c'est 5.8
millions tests qui ont été effectuées
donc lorsque l'une des limites au
dépistage parce que les services étaient
saturés ça nous a posé des problèmes
pour les chercheurs c'est un indicateur
précieux disponible depuis le début de
la pandémie qui perd son sens at il de
chercheuse en santé publique qui
travaillent avec des données je
comprenais pas comment le gouvernement
allait pouvoir avancer dans la pandémie
jusque là on aurait plus d'informations
il faut pourtant continuer à surveiller
le virus mais par quels moyens
[Musique]
mathieu mahut giroux et épidémiologiste
à l'université mcgill depuis deux ans il
projette avec ses collègues le nombre
d'hospitalisations que pourrait
engendrer l'épidémie il calcule aussi le
taux de reproduction du virus
le taux de reproduction effectifs de
virus est un indicateur épidémiologique
qui permet de suivre la transmission du
virus si on a une personne infectée
belle nombre moyen d'infections
secondaires donc de transmission de
cette personne là nous indique à quelle
vitesse ça se propage citant odeurs on a
une courbe exponentielle
cissé a un c'est que ça reste stable
c'est en mode en baisse à 10 millions le
hic c'est que ce tout était calculé à
partir des hospitalisations mais aussi
des cas qui ont chuté quand les critères
de dépistage ont été restreints un casse
tête pour les experts
on voulait continuer à utiliser les
codes parce que c'est un indicateur qui
répond un peu plus rapidement aux
changements de transmission du virus
donc ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a
regardé un peu quels groupes d'individus
il n'y avait pas eu de changement au
critère de dépistage
[Musique]
par exemple les travailleurs de la santé
où les gens qui doivent subir une
opération ont toujours accès aux tests
diagnostiques les chercheurs ont revu
leur calcul à partir des données issues
de ces groupes devenus en quelque sorte
des groupes témoins ou sentinelles si on
regarde par exemple pour l'année 2000 21
ces groupes là on voit qu'il ya quand
même une bonne très bonne corrélation
entre les coteaux taux et les tendances
dans ces groupes prioritaires ces
groupes sentinelles la méthode n'est pas
parfaite les groupes sentinelle ne sont
pas nécessairement représentatifs de la
population générale d'ailleurs
l'intervalle de confiance des calculs
leur incertitude a augmenté avec cette
nouvelle approche
l'incertitude roxane borgès da silva l'a
bien senti quand les tests à grande
échelle ont été interrompues au québec
c'était impensable pour moi de se
retrouver dans cette situation là et
avec les collègues en fait on s'est dit
qu'on allait justement profité de cette
occasion pour combler ce trou
l'économiste spécialisé dans les
politiques de santé a lancé une enquête
chaque semaine depuis la mi janvier 3000
québécois sont interrogés pour savoir
s'ils ont eu lakovic 19 cette première
stratégie cela ce qu'on appelle la
stratégie d'échantillonnage direct on
leur pose également la question
des questions sur leurs réseaux combien
de personnes dans votre entourage ont
attrapé la co vide
l'enquète évalue latin et du réseau
social des répondants en leur demandant
par exemple combien de médecins font
partie leur entourage ou combien de
personnes non vaccinées contre la coved
ils connaissent comme on sait combien il
ya de médecins ou encore de non vaccinés
au québec les chercheurs en déduisent la
taille du réseau des personnes sondées
on est capable en fait du coup
d'extrapoler les de connaître la taille
du réseau de chacun de ces trois mille
personnes qu'on enquête grâce aux
réponses qui nous donne et avec la
réponse au nombre de personnes qui ont
attrapé la copie dans leur entourage on
est capable d'avoir une estimation
beaucoup plus robuste et c'est ce qu'on
appelle la méthode de l'amplificateur
par réseau avec cette méthode le groupe
a estimé qu' entre la mi décembre et la
mi février
près de deux millions de québécois ont
attrapé la coved 19
un nombre semblable à celui avancé par
la santé publique
loin des écouvillon et des enquêtes
statistiques
d'autres chercheurs traque le virus dans
les égouts
depuis le début de la pandémie plusieurs
projets de recherche ont montré qu'on
peut évaluer la transmission du strass
kobe 2 grâce aux eaux usées
l'un d'eux a été coordonnée par le
professeur de génie civil dominique
frigo le virus qui doivent s
respiratoire peut quand même se
reproduire dans les intestins c'est
comme ça que par exemple certains
individus ont des symptômes et testino
mais il savait aussi que le virus est
relarguer par le phénomène qu'on la joue
et on va relâcher du virus dans les eaux
usées et en quantifiant la quantité
russe on peut déterminer si la quantité
d'infection dans la population augmente
ou diminue
d'antan
l'an dernier les chercheurs ont mené des
analyses dans plusieurs municipalités
québécoises
on a démontré à québec durant la
troisième vague qu'on pouvait prédire
l'augmentation des cas de quatre à sept
jours avant les tests cliniques et avec
savons leur santé publique de la
capitale-nationale utiliser ce type de
données là pour déterminer le changement
du mode alerte
le projet de dominique frigon a été
interrompue début décembre au tout début
de la cinquième vague faute de
financement récemment québec a annoncé
son intention de reprendre l'analyse des
eaux usées un outil de plus dans
l'arsenal de surveillance et
d'information complémentaire mais c'est
une information qui nous permet de voir
l'évolution de la pandémie des
infections dans la population bien
entendu loup ne dit pas tout en
particulier si elle peut informer sur la
quantité de virus en circulation
elle ne dit pas qui est infecté
pour ça il faudra peut-être s'approcher
de ce qui se fait déjà pour suivre
d'autres virus par exemple pour la
grippe il ya des les gmf les groupes de
médecine familiale où toutes les
patients qui voient ils vont les
dépister puis ils sont capables de
mesurer un peu la transmission dans ces
groupes le mans des groupes sentinelles
des enquêtes des eaux usées ou encore
des études de séroprévalence comme ça se
fait depuis le début de la pandémie pour
belle fille qui a développé des
anticorps contre le virus bref un
éventail de moyens pour anticiper sa
circulation dans une gestion de la
pandémie on ne peut pas naviguer sans
donner et en l'absence de tests pcr
accessible à toute la population et de
données fiables il faut se retourner
vers des méthodes alternatives comme
celle là va falloir continuer à investir
grandement dans nos systèmes de
surveillance et une vigie pour s'assurer
qu'on puisse avoir la meilleure
information possible si pour avoir une
augmentation de la transmission
parce que dans le futur vivre avec le
virus
ça voudra aussi dit le garder à l'oeil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]